these days I have noticed you don't like
wearing shirts now gotta be real D if I
look like you I don't think I'd wear a
shirt either I'm from Miami we're
serious in Miami this is we call it no
shouting no shouting this is like what
you wearing no shirt shouting sods you
can't get in without like shirt and
shoes we want to go in like that like
after the lake or something but so what
do you do to treat yourself you work out
you're such a beast you work at all the
time what do you do to treat yourself
food wise or anything why a food wise
every month cake yeah my goodness
chocolate cake unbelievable ice cream
with that it's amazing yeah I also love
you know after a good workout
I love having vodka and Muslim like
Bakken protein [ __ ] muscle oh wait
you mix vodka with a protein shake yeah
yeah yeah so it's basically like uppers
and downers
you getting fit while you're getting
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this